[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حوار فرنسا اليوم نستضيف
الوزير اللبناني السابق ورئيس التيار
الوطني الحر جبران بسيل اهلا بكم
في فرنسا
وفكره او برنامج
تحقق الهدف من الزياره بعيد عن كل ما يقال
بالاعلام يعني من تصورات وتخيلات غير
حقيقيه
الرئاسه الفرنسيه
احد اوجهها الشهور الرئاسي واهم الان هو
اللي لازم نبلش فيه الشهور الحكومي
الغياب الاصلاح
المؤسس الوحيد القائمه هي مجلس النواب وما
بتقدر بحسب نظامنا انه توم واحده من البلد
ففي اولويه لها انتخاب رئيس
حكومي تقدر هي والرئيس بالتعاون مع المجلس
النيابي ينفذوا برنامج اصلاحى الهدف هو
اصلاح البلد واصلاح الاقتصاد والماليه
العامه
وبالتالي الوصول للهدف طلب وجود رئيس
الاتصالات
كامل حل بيخرجنا من يعني الجنود اللي نحن
فيه
ولا يتعلق فقط بالاسماء موضوع مش موضوع
اسماء يعني اكيد توصل بالاخر لانتخاب اسم
بس الموضوع من حصنه لما نقدر نحط تصور
كامل كيف نقدر نوصل للاصلاح لبنان عنده
ازمه كمان مركب من الداخل ومن الخارج
وبدها بالفعل بالدمعناش من الداخل ومن
الخارج منيح انه الخارج مش فاضي للبنين
تقدر اللبنانيين ينتخبوا منهم يريدون مش
صحيح انه في مرشحين مدمنين من الخارج في
اليوم فرصه للبنانيين يعملوا رئيس لبناني
[موسيقى]
وحدنا ومع مجموعه من الافريكان الاخرى يا
اللي اذا قدرنا اتفقنا معهم حتى
عددنا لا يكفي لنصل ثلثين المجلس او لنصف
المجلس
التوافق ضروري مصر انك لست مرشحا ولا تدعم
ترشيح سليمان فرنجيه انا انا لم اترشح لكي
لا اعقد الامور لم اترشح لكي لا نصل الى
الفراغ لم اترشح لكي نصل الى تفيهم على
رئيس يكون مدعوم بما يكفي لا ينجح بعهد ف-
همم لم اترشح لتفادي كلها الامور اذا
القصه بتضلها كمان هنا بثياغ
[موسيقى]
غلطان لكم
يعني باختصار لا يعني لا نتفق معه
بالبرنامج
السياسي الاصلاحاح ببناء الدوله
ما تفهمنا لما اوقف اطراف اخرى مثل حزب
الله
بحمايه البلد وحمايه المقاولون وغيره انما
نرى الاولويه اليوميه ببناء الدوله من دون
ما يتعارض بناء الدوله مع حمايه لبنان
على اساس انك انت من يعطل الاصلاح او انك
جزء من المنظومه
الان يصفون وكانكم انتم من يعطل الانتقام
هلا كل واحد في التهم يعني كيف ما بيريد
اول شيء نحن ابعد ما نكون عن المنظومه نحن
يعني جينا لانه نغير المنظومه نغير
سياساتها ولكن التغيير بده يكون من الداخل
نظامنا هيك بحتم علينا من الخارج لا ينفع
ما في امكانيه لانك تغير فلما بتفوت تتغير
من الداخل ما بصير جزء من المنظومه ثانيا
نحن كنا بنعطل عم بنعطل لو فعلا ميرسنا
حقنا
نحن اكبر كت لبناني
وهذا الموقع بنظام اللبناني الطائفه هو
للطائف المرونيه
بكل بساطه من تسهيل الامور وتنازل عن حق
اساسي لا نسهل لانه وضع البلد ما بيسمع
بالفراخ اذا بده يصير انه ما ترشحنا كان
سهل الامور تتصور تصير انها تعطيل
طويلا
انه نقدر نكسر هالجمود هذا ونعمل الحركه
المطلوبه الداخليه
لانه الفراغ مميت اليوم بلبنان همم مش
متعلق بس بموقع قصدي جمهوريه متعلق بان
احنا نوصل لشلل كامل الدولي
لا لم يحصل
امكانيه اعاده تسويه على غرار ما حصل في
المره الماضيه ممكن اعتقد الموضوع
متعلق بقرار هو ياخذه
كيف المؤقت على الحياه السياسيه نحن كنا
بنتمنى هذا الشيء ما يكون لانه في وضع مش
سليم اليوم بالطائف السنه بلبنان ويجب مو
علاشته هو جزء اساسي
بياخذ قرار بالعوده طبعا احنا
ملزمه ومقتنعين بالتعاطي ما هو جزء اساسي
ومكون اساسي بالولد
امريكي
العلاقه مع حزب الله لكن ايضا بالفساد كما
قال الامريكي الان هناك حديث عن انك تسع
لرفع هذه العقوبات وان قطر تلعب دورا
هل هذا صحيح
ما في غيره وسبت
مع حزب الله ثانيا انا اقوم بمسحه مكشوف
من موجب حقي بيتقدم بالمراجعه همم
الاداريه اللازمه لدى الامريكيين لرفع
العقوبات لانه ليس هناك اي دليل او ورقه
او اي اثبات الدموه بطلب مني مباشره على
عده مرات لا يكونوا مستنين فيله سبب
المعلن بوضع العقوبات كثير كثير
مع اسرائيل الامور ماتت همم مفتوحه للمزيد
من
الاطلاق
ترسيم الحدود والتعصم اللي حصل هو موضوع
العقوبات
بالمقابل هذا الاتفاق لازم يكون نوع من
قدوه او نموذج لان نعتمد لحل مشاكلنا
بلبنان بعتبر هذه من اهم المشاكل اللي
قدرنا حليناها لانه فيها تعقيدات كبيره
وفيها اسرائيل موضوع رئاسه جمهوريه اسهل
انما اذا فتنه اللي هي
نعيلش موضوع حقوق ونعطي التطمينات اللي
لازم الى الاطراف ايه ونقدر نترك القرار
اللبناني بالكامل انما نوفر له الدعم
الخارجي لانه جزء من مشكلتنا خارجين ان
احنا
معرض لحصار من الخارج ما راح ينجح رئيس
اذا ما ازيل هذا الحديث
بين الاصلاح والحصار ما بين الداخل
والخارج والحل لازم يكون متكامل
هنا المدخل
المدخل هو نامن توافق لبناني لبناني
انما نوفر له الاجواء الخارجيه اللي ما
بتخربه او يلي بتطمن انه الكل طرف الداخل
اللبناني متخوف من شيء نقدر نطمن شخصيه
التصور
[موسيقى]
اهم من الشخص لانه اذا جاء اي شخص
ما كان في اقوى من العماد هون رئيس
جمهوريه وعنده الامكانيات بس كان ناقص هذا
الداخليه
ولما جاء التخريب الخارجي
بالخارجيه اللي بن وضعته علينا من الخارج
ان تزال اذا ازيلت مثل من عامل باتفاق
الترسيم وفي الاليه اللي بنقدر نعملها من
خلالها وبتشعر الناس حاله ان هي يعني حققت
ما تريد من غير جيده نغير جيده
الحل بيتوفر
يعني التوضيح فقط يعني هل يمكن اعتبار
التيار او شخص ما شخصكم يعني صانع الرئيس
بالشكل
على الصعيد الوطني لانه اكبر دول ضروري
انه هذا الشيء من الطبيعي انه يكون عندنا
الاول فيه طبيعي ولكن احنا منك الا المجلس
النيه احنا وحده 20 128 وبالتالي لا يمكن
لاحد في لبنان ان يصنع رئيس لوحده من دون
ما يتامل توافق في استطاعه احد ان يعطل
وصول الرئيس ولكن حتى لوحده ما بيقدر حتى
ما في حدا بلبنان لوحده بيقدر يعطل في
مجموعه ناس بتامن الثالث
لا احد يبدو عم بحكي يعني انه مستعجل ما
فيه الكفايه لنوقف كنا فينا نمنع الوصول
للشهور ما معنى يعني هلا الهدف انه نوقف
اطاله الامد تبعه فالكل مسؤول همم
مسؤول عن الخروج منه وبتامل نحن بنيه عم
نشتغل ونتحرك بالخارج ونتعامل انا اللي
ايد ممدوده لانه وتعاون لانه عنجد نحن
نسال على حل
انتخاب الرئيس ليس الحال في لبنان انتخاب
الرئيس هو مدخل الحل
وجزء من الحلب دخلنا على مدخل ثاني هو
وجود حكومه بالتعاون مع الرئيس وبدخلنا
على المدخل الثالث انه مع مجلس النواب
يصير في الاصلاحات بالنسبه لو سمحت يعني
انقل ما يقال يعني يخصومكم في لبنان
يتهمونكم بانكم تعطلون وانا مثلا ترتيبات
في الخارج نتيجه همم انتم جزء من تحالف
بطبيعه الحال المحلف بالله الذي ينظر
اليها ايضا ان له مصالح لا ترتبط بالظروف
لبنان هذا ما يقال في لبنان نحن التيار
مستقل عن الخارج وعن الداخل نتفاهم مع حزب
الله على كثير من الامور
واحد مثلا
نعتبر اليوم انه لازم تكون الاولويه هي
البحث عن اسم من ضمن برنامج ماشي
نتفق عليه نحن حزب الله وغير حزب الله
اكيد امال همم سلمان الفرنجيه والاخرين
وكل من يرغب وكل هذا الشيء مش محصور بحدا
هذا مفتوح للكل لان احنا اليوم انه هذه هي
الاولويه ونسعى لتامين الارضيه الداخليه
لهذا الشيء
والغطاء الخارجي بما معنى المظله الحيمه
لايه فيهم لبناني شكرا لك على الوزيره
اهلا وسهلا وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا والى
اللقاء في حوار جديد على فرنسا
[موسيقى]